hello reject nation
it's Greg Alva here you know it Raquel
Kushner you might have seen on the Schmo
down G is also on Twitter she tweets a
lot always about God and you know how
Lord Jesus has saved her life in all
these situations and how she's aiming to
be the next contestant on next season's
bachelor and she come I worked on that
job you know yes and an improv no no
buts yes and I'm not an improv person
well that's why you do way worse than me
on the show so on the Schmo down
rachel is very much known for being
great in the Oscar category it is wildly
impressive how much she knows in that
category so I thought you know Oscars
are coming up right season okay March
March yep it's the first weekend in
March and I cannot remember the exact
date forgive me
what are you doing here Joe and I are
gonna give our Oscar predictions for the
interesting Oscar categories that people
actually tuned in for that's right guys
best costume design I like that one I
know you probably like them all I do
deserve a category you don't like I
don't even really watch the Oscars I
just wait for the lists to come out and
I go cool good for them we're gonna do
the big ones though the big ones that
everyone waits to the three to four hour
ceremony for that's how they do it right
they start with like the supporting ones
in the beginning like they hook you okay
doing one of the best supporting actor
actress early on and then yeah then your
special effects and your music and sound
editing and sound mixing yeah the very
important one absolutely but they the
ones were there like get them off on the
stage work your way up this so will take
a turn each odds are rachel is
gonna be wrong I know this is why I'm
gonna be yeah I can literally well know
which is better than her for every
category we'll probably do something
where here's who I'd want to win here's
who I think will probably win so we'll
do it that way and sometimes I'm looking
at my list and sometimes my probably's
are gonna be the ones who I who I
already want to win anyway yeah yeah
what a convenient Oscar sir do you paint
a pool how you do yeah Wow how much
youth what's the most you've thrown down
in the pool oh my friends and I are
chief we play five-dollar pool oh oh I
can play with you guys
yeah guys keep in mind opinions are all
objective so these are the only correct
opinions all right so if you're upset
don't be you're only mad at yourself
I'll kick this off since I know I'm
probably the better guesser here that's
not a double negative tellin yourself
that
Best Supporting Actor okay all right man
I really should have thought this
through a little more now that I'm
thinking about for Best Supporting Actor
I feel like the one who I would honestly
want to win his Richard Jenkins he's the
one I want to win for shape of water
even though I didn't think he was the
best performance in j-pal water he's
that actor who is always in these
supporting roles that always shine and I
always always loved him in the movie
season and I thought he had a really
nice delightful surprising genuine
performance that helped elevate the film
I thought it would be just oh that's
cool Richard Jenkins isn't here but I
wasn't expecting him to elevate the film
and he is such an important supporting
character for Sally Hawkins in that
movie itself I would like him to win who
do I think will win you know I don't
think Sam Rockwell will win I'm honestly
thinking army hammer might have a shot
interest yeah I think army hammer might
have a shot because the Oscars can be
surprising to from the other categories
and call me by your name is very much an
austere type movie absolutely and I
think armie hammer is great and call me
by your name movie of the year
Armie Hammer has that subtle performance
and you know people sometimes give flack
to the officers when they like to praise
the game performance
what how did they put that you know but
I think it's way more than like a gay
performance no acid yeah it's a
beautiful beautiful performance and a
later performance like when I saw that
movie I was with a group of people who
were all going very back and forth I
think he was manipulative I think he was
just using him I think he was messed up
and then I was in the audience going
well no I don't think that was the case
I think he was just as the 80s over the
movie took place it's confusing for him
and he has a line in there that shows
that he's not exactly comfortable with
being gay so I really appreciate it the
hell out of first performances it's very
authentic I guess these are both who I
would like to win but I could actually
see armie hammer winning I'm just gonna
take a long shot there and say on the
hammer
I like your pick okay who are you who's
you're probably Hootie would you want
and who do you think was actually one
who I want is also actually in call me
by your name but that would be Michael
Stuhlbarg I'm not the first person to
say this but still Varg is the MVP of
the Oscar season cuz he was in the post
he was in the shape of water and he was
in call me by your name but there is a
scene at the end of Call Me by earning
between father and son yes you can call
it like the most Oscar baby scene would
necessarily be wrong but it's beautiful
beautiful delivery so well and it's such
tears in my eyes I think Michael
Stuhlbarg is just a phenomenal actor
I've always thought so just really
excited that he's in so many of great
movies this season and he hasn't really
been popping up on like he wasn't
nominated Golden Globes if the SAG
Awards or anything and I'm like come on
people like I really truly think and I
mean I think army hammer is wonderful in
the movie as well but if I had to choose
between the two to get a nomination I
really had my fingers crossed that stool
Bart gets a nomination and if I got to
choose he would be the winner as far as
who I'm pretty sure is going to win I
think the clear front-runner is Willem
Dafoe for the Florida Project really
yeah most of the critics circles gave it
to him early on and he's definitely been
you know in a Gotham awards I believe
and the Critics associations and Sam
Rockwell won at the Golden Globes where
we all know the Golden Globes aren't the
most predictive no of award ceremonies
but it does sort of feel like it might
be coming down to those two it was
we'll have a little ways for the Oscars
and momentum changes of the two I
certainly would much prefer willem dafoe
to win I'm not the biggest three
billboards fan but you just wait for
that armie hammer speech because I like
Twitter I will shout you out and I will
be like Gregg got it right armie hammer
I've put him I put him in my list of who
I think for Whitney Arizona they away
but I'm just gonna say that in case he
just surprisingly wins I don't think you
will but I wanted his boom there cuz
it's my video and I'll do whatever I
want you're not editing it guys okay
Best Supporting Actress who I liked win
for this is Laurie Metcalf
I saw Lady Bird recently and I
absolutely adore her performance and it
might be because she reminded me of a
lot of women I've grown up with because
of that fact I was like such an
authentic [ __ ] perform is it's so
real it's that mother who's very
judgmental we can also tell us very
caring but she plays off of every other
actor well very in the moment and I was
very much moved by her performance
because it's one of those performances
where there's a lot of different things
going on inside than what's going on the
outside and I think that's very hard to
balance who I think will win will
honestly be the Golden Globe winner
Allison Janney I think I think she will
actually win for aya Tanja she does a
great performance in it and it kind of
just seems like it's about time Allison
Janney wins and that's the vibe I'm
getting
no she's won a whole lot of Emmys and
Golden Globes I know
mark my words Rachel I don't get nervous
when you disagree with me I think you
probably nailed both the top
frontrunners Allison Janney or Allison
Janney and Laurie Metcalf oh that's what
you meant yeah yeah I'm really I'm
really good at listening to pixel I
think will win is Laurie Metcalf I think
that Allison Janney's performance in I
Tania is is the louder one then not
saying better or worse I'm just saying
the flashy one and the one that's sort
of more memorable in its intensity and
energy and things like that but Laurie
Metcalf like you said is so internalized
but so affecting yeah and her chemistry
with Saoirse Ronan and and that
mother-daughter dynamic yeah yeah so
relatable and honest and and I I just
feel like Oscar voters are going to
acknowledge that I want to pick sort of
a dark horse as who I would like to win
that's Holly Hunter from the big sick I
didn't know no toys it was just such a a
movie where I went in thinking yeah
rom-com early in the year yeah it'll be
fine and I came out like choked there's
so much about this movie the layers in
this movie it's not just about a
relationship but the family
relationships and religion and culture
and then this crazy thing happens to
this couple who aren't even together
when she get out and then he has to make
all these decisions and then Kemal
Nanjiani I think it's the big six was
one of my biggest surprises of the year
in terms of a movie there's so many
layers to it it's about relationships
not just romantic ones but family and
culture and I adored Kumail Nanjiani
'he's relationship with his girlfriend's
parents yeah because you know she's sick
and in a coma and so he has to relate to
her parents and he had broken up with
her and so I did the dynamic is
brilliant Ray Romano and Holly Hunter
but Holly Hunter just brought something
extra to it where I really felt it and I
loved her chemistry with Camille wow you
know you might be right that might be
one of the most under recognized
performances it was an early in the year
sometimes those fail to get remembered
at Oscar season so like and also it's
Javert - yeah romantic comedies tend not
to but that's the thing it's not just a
romantic comedy so much more than
anything it's made a lot of top-ten
lists in a lot of my friends loved it so
hopefully it gets remembered it's some
in some way at the Oscars but I'd like
that to be Holly Hunter for nomination
at least impressive impressive choice
this is why you had me yes like just
know I'm right there what Best Actor
category so curious to hear who I think
will win the big question is knots
people big question I feel like it's
gonna be a toss-up between Gary Oldman
Louis it's so hard to pick because Gary
Oldman has a bigger performance has the
performance a lot of monologuing you
know in Churchill it's a historical
performance he's I was all the makeup
it's a much bigger body language
performance but this is Daniel day-lewis
who's known too usually when the Oscar
when it's a big role and it's his last
performance supposedly I don't know if
they're gonna do something well this is
last performance so we might as well
just give it to him and get him gonna
have another shot later I think between
the two who would probably win at this
point the Oscars just giving it to Danny
Lewis is he has a great job in Phantom
threat but it's a more subtle
performance and every performance that
really builds a lot more which in some
ways is arguably a better performance
it's just a very different performance
but I feel like for what Oscars are that
Gary Oldman will probably win for for
usually what the Oscars tend to lean
towards if this wasn't Daniel day-lewis
his last movie I would for sure be
saying Gary Oldman that's the difference
here who I would like to win is someone
who I just don't think it's gonna get
nominated at all this is my personal
pick of who I would really like to win
is I talked a lot about him on this
channel in this specific movie but it's
real awful is my dark horse Hugh Jackman
as Wolverine for Logan that is an actual
Oscar caliber comic book leading
performance in that film and I don't
really care if these had 15 years of
preparation because it still takes place
later and it's still an embodiment of a
role and there's still so much life I
don't know in terms of like the male
leading performances that was the one
that really hit home hard for me I feel
like it's the performances should be
more recognised and I don't think he's
even gonna get nominated it would be so
cool if he did it would be so cool if he
did him at work we didn't mention it but
Patrick Stewart and Best Supporting
Actor yeah would have been yeah I just
wish that the comic book movies would
get a little more love especially when
it's like that yeah I would like to see
Hugh Jackman
not for the greatest showmen but for
that movie specifically because I
thought that was something very special
and I think it's even a more challenging
job in some ways when you have a
character because normally when you get
a few movies in you're kind of sick of a
character and the fact that this was his
tenth movie and it was his best
Wolverine performance says a lot that's
my prediction there well I think you're
spot on that it's gonna come down to
Oldman and Daniel day-lewis my issue
with both is that in some ways I think
that if either one of them won it
wouldn't be necessarily because of their
performance I think it would be
political yeah like Oldman I mean the
fact that he hasn't won an Oscar and the
fact that he's only been nominated once
14 he's a travesty yeah and the Oscars
might want to be interested in making it
up to him by giving him this win I do
think he was wonderful as Winston
Churchill but it's not even I think my
top three favorite performances of the
year in January is again because
everybody is under the impression and
you know we always have the ticket with
a grain of salt like does he mean it
when he says this is his last movie
because if he does the Academy voters
might be keeping that in the back of
their mind I mean it would only be him
as what he's for horse oh yeah you know
then he will have been that man who won
the most Oscars yes that's right yeah I
am also edging towards I believe the
Academy will give Oldman the Oscar for
me personally I'm hoping and I know it
will not happen
t-midi sha'lame wins for call me by your
name yes I think it is the most honest
performance I've seen all year he just
made me cry that last shot the credits
shot of him oh yeah oh my god yeah like
but it's the whole movie this movie
doesn't work if you don't believe him in
every way and he just struck me as any
18 year old or 17 year old young person
who's falling in love for the first time
feels and this isn't even about gender
this is about anybody at that age in
their life this is how you feel and your
emotions run the gamut and it's face it
was so open and honest and I just he was
a rebel
to me this year I'm really surprised by
how under-recognized it's getting call
me by your name I feel like it got early
recognition from the critic circles but
like it was shut out at the Golden
Globes it hasn't won anything with the
national broadcast associate Awards but
I feel like it's the kind of movie like
a moonlight which was an early Indian
lauded festival type of movie that sort
of flew under the radar for a couple
months
when lala land became the the big talked
about movie moonlight was under the
radar but then made our last second push
toward you personally I'm hoping call me
by your name does a similar place I
think it can I do because it's
especially in terms of performances I
know we tend to go for like the Gary
Oldman calling by her name that that
type of performance is in some ways way
more challenging because the camera just
lingers on you and it's about as being
authentic yeah you don't relate to
Winston Churchill because that's an
observing type of performance that's not
a performance or you just observe life
yeah and I agree because he is amazing
in that movie for sure hey guys
Greg the editor here so as I was editing
this video I realized we totally skipped
over the Best Actress category in here
and I thought we should probably include
that or else all looks sexist and I'll
look degrading to Rachel well that's not
the case my pick for Best Actress would
have to be Frances McDormand she's the
one who I would want to win and she's
the one who I honestly think will win
damn it Todd
here's Rachel's opinion I don't know how
this happened Greg I feel kind of guilty
and a sense of betrayal towards my own
gender for forgetting the Best Actress
category especially considering how
stacked it is this year this is actually
going to be one of the harder ones to
predict right now the two frontrunners
seem to be Frances McDormand for three
billboards and Sally Hawkins for the
shape of water and I could honestly see
it going either way but as we've talked
about other categories momentum is a big
thing and there's still a lot of time
for the momentum to shift before the
Oscar ballots are due so I think Saoirse
Ronan could also sneak in there which
just goes to show you that this is not
an easy one to pick but if I had to I
think the Academy is gonna go with Sally
Hawkins I just think the critics have
been behind her since day one I know for
instance McDormand has a huge following
and even though I didn't love the movie
I loved her in it but her Golden Globe
win does not assure her an Academy Award
win for that one in terms of who I hope
wins I honestly think that Meryl Streep
is the best she's been in a long time in
the post I also in terms of Dark Horse
candidates go really really like Jessica
Chastain in Molly's game for my pick I'm
going with another slight dark horse I
think she's guaranteed a nomination but
I don't think she's gonna win this year
and that is Margo Roby for I Tanya this
is a truly fantastic biting funny
interesting thoughtful film and Margot
Robbie just continues to prove that she
is more than just a pretty face she is
so talented she's got such great timing
especially comedic timing and I was
blown away by her performance in I Tania
or chemistry was fast and Stan and
Allison Janney and everything about it
was with stellar so she's my Dark Horse
pick but uh but I am thinking that uh
Sally Hawkins is gonna take this one
alright let's get back to the main video
Greg well for Best Director who I think
will win I think we'll begin with us
world I think he turned it I think he
has after great work with Pacific it's
fun gamble the Toro well I think what he
crafted with shape of water is a
masterpiece I don't know if you liked it
I did I adore that film that is a movie
that's [ __ ] directed because it is
it's got everything visuals and
performances to the fact that you can do
both in one movie telematic visual
experience with awesome performance
as well is really hard to get down and I
think he absolutely nailed it so
rightfully so I think he should win but
who would I would like to win I feel
like I should say gear up a little tour
of who I would like just made a very
convincing would like to see at least
get a nomination is Jordan Peele forget
out I would at least like to see that
happen because what he did just
surprised - Shh I'm not a [ __ ] a person
and I liked that
this is incredibly smart it's a clever
rewatching experience that's very much
composed I think it's a film that he
should get an Oscar nomination for did
he get one for Golden Globes no but he
did for one of the big Critics Awards
the film critic says no yeah yeah I
think I think he really deserves one I
mean not that a nomination means
everything but he that least deserves
that recognition you know I think he
stands a good chance of getting a
nomination yeah yeah okay cool what do
you got there you got all right I think
you're right I think this again the
Golden Globes isn't usually necessarily
indicative of the Oscars but I think the
momentum is behind del'toro I think that
ever since I don't know the premiere to
Toronto Film Festival but like that's
when you started hearing people really
talk about it and then it just was had a
very slow release and everybody I knew
that saw it was like you've got to go
see ya
this twist on a fairy town like you said
it is stunning to look at it is so
brilliantly shot in the colors and the
concepts and it's got this fairytale
feel to it but it's darker and more
complex in some ways but very simple and
others it's just such a beautiful film
and you can tell his acceptance speech
at the Golden Globes like his his love
of monsters and everything it's like
that was a labor of love for him and I
think that comes across and shows yeah I
think that the Academy is very likely to
acknowledge that and because it's such a
ridiculously open race in terms of just
who's even gonna get nominated you know
that any sort of groundswell or feeling
of momentum and I feel like he has it
right now so if he even remotely keeps
that I think
he wins I mean I think Greta Gerwig is
getting a nomination I really feel like
she's going to especially after the
upset I think there's a lot of open arms
that she hasn't been for like the Golden
Globes and whatnot I think she fully
deserves it because while this isn't a
shape of water it's not a director
forward film
those actors had like her direction for
them I think yeah what should count in
this I really need her to get in the
nomination my pick for who I would want
to win and this is actually really
strange I didn't think I was gonna say
this
I thought Dunkirk was incredible really
I am NOT a Christopher Nolan de beauté
like I love some of his movies I like
certain other ones I find him to be a
somewhat and it is not again this is not
a criticism it's not a bad thing but I
find him to be a colder kind of
filmmaker more clinical more story
driven than necessarily character driven
and when it's character driven they tend
to be not somebody that I find myself
relating to easily doesn't mean I don't
love his movies don't enjoy them I
definitely do Don Kirk does fall into
that category you want to talk about a
directed movie like what he had to do to
accomplish this film and do it in a way
that's unlike other war movies and I
know that's why some people didn't like
it but it's actually the reason why I
did and I love that our movies this
isn't Saving Private Ryan this isn't a
character study of a group of men
surviving war this is about thousands
upon thousands that did not think they
were gonna survive this moment the big
picture look at how that went down
and then you just have these snippets
with these guys and you don't know their
backstory this is what all of them were
going through and that's the feeling I
got from it to top that off the
cinematography it's second to none the
sound design is second to none I loved
Hans Zimmer's score I felt like it was a
annex movie-going experience in IMAX and
all of that stuff it might be my
favorite Nolan film I think it's too
early for me to say that in a few years
when you're looking but when I'm looking
back in his filmography very well could
be wow you make a great argument thank
you cuz Dunkirk not even like my my top
favorite
a lot of people didn't love it and I
totally get that but what you said I was
like you know what you made a great
point about that movie though is in
terms of like a directed film and the
performance is even though it's not
heavy on character the performances are
still great and you know the actors knew
the characters and that's all that
really mattered for what Nolan's film
was all right here we go
the big one I mean I think I know what
you we're both gonna predict who we
think will win and I can tell you right
now that's gonna change for me every
week for the next yeah yeah this is the
craziest year in terms of being so open
and momentum is gonna play a massive
role and it's whatever's got the
momentum going into those final couple
weeks of voting I'm dying to know what
that's gonna be my prediction is not
really based on a whole lot because I
don't think anybody can make an accurate
prediction of this stage what do I think
will win honestly like you're bringing
up your point about moonlight and lala
land earlier I have on my phone call me
by your name is the one I think will win
that seems like an Oscar type of Best
Picture winner to me after watching that
movie I think it's really damn good and
I'm like yeah I could see this winning
Best Picture
I can never seen you and I while I
really do like that movie a hell of a
lot I don't think it's the one I would
personally want to see you know but I
wouldn't be upset if it went up I'll put
it like that and if you're one I'd be
like okay that's awesome I think the one
I would want to win hey I think Logan
should get a nomination but that's not
the one I'm choosing I think the one I
would want to win is actually shape of
water be amazing if there's yarn or film
like that yeah it would be to me the
shape of water is the reason I go to the
movies it's something like that where it
has it all or I'm crying I'm laughing
I'm on edge Jam swept up like it's all
these vast emotions of experiencing and
it's imaginative too because while I
appreciate films like three billboards
or call me by your name or Lady Bird
which are very much about life because I
feel like those are just as hearts in a
lot of ways to play like I don't know if
Guillermo del Toro can do a ladybird
call me by your name you know he
probably could very interesting shape of
water you know the fact that it's so
John Rowe base and the fact that it's so
imaginative and doesn't lose any of its
emotional core and has a lot of
important themes in there something that
I would really like to see when I would
like to see it but like we were time I
heard her calling by her name hasn't
been like winning a bunch of Awards or
whatever but I could definitely see the
Oscars going you know what calling by
her name is the best one if there's any
category the Oscars it surprised you and
it's the best mature one out of all the
categories that's the one we were like
whoa I'm gonna have to go calling by
your names that way I'm not surprised
when it wins I'm just gonna start with
who I want to win yeah
really that I would be so so happy if
the Academy recognized it's like in like
you said in the way that it recognized
moonlight which is actually one of the
reasons why I'm kind of wonder if that's
the reason it won't and I didn't want to
say that but I was yeah to that same
point though in terms of momentum and
how moonlight kind of snuck under the
radar under lala land I think the same
thing is going to happen this year and I
think it's going to happen with Lady
Bird I feel like only there's there's
there's a groundswell of honestly like a
little bit of backlash and why Greta
Gerwig wasn't nominated for the Golden
Globes and whatnot and I feel like that
it's it's politics but it plays into
everything and then everything that's
going on in the industry and with the
different movements and female
empowerment I think that's going to play
into it it's a fantastic movie
so that will play into it and I feel
like right now three billboards and
shape of water are sort of the ones
people are talking about I also think
the post is gonna get back into the
picture it is an Oscar movie
it's Spielberg it's Hanks it's Streep
and it's good I in the biggest Meryl
Streep fan you will find she should not
have been nominated for Florence Foster
Jenkins I would be very happy if she's
nominated for this okay I thought that
that it's a very good movie it's so
topical is Mike yeah as to why I think
it'll get back into the conversation I
think there's a lot of players and
whereas last year was just - I think all
of these will sort of like have their
upturns
be like oh fast the front-runner and
then next week I'll be oh this is the
front-runner but I think when the dust
clears my guts telling me that it's
gonna be Lady Bird on top Rachel I don't
know if you can hear the comments on
this video right now but they're all
going wow Greg made all the right
predictions Greg is the one I'm gonna
scream so this is not what I am walking
your number get ready to feel
embarrassed by the comments that are
like Rachel's guesses are away
who do you think will be your ride me or
Rachel I have sat here next to Rachel
and I have gone I think Rachel's right
every single one of them I made sure to
go first
anything you say I'm gonna be like uh
yeah she makes a great point about
Rachel sir sir thank you for being here
you better have made this video what it
is thank you for being here guys you can
follow Rachel Cushing on twitter at
twitter.com/zeromd
follow her John want as many creepy
followers to follow you as possible I
know that's the target market looking
for if you're a creep subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell to get creeped out every time we're
up on videos coming face your unobjected
a patreon spawn it's like a second
channel good die Mike